tout reste donc possible pour cette
équipe de france entraînée par daniel
costantini
celui-ci après 15 ans de service
quittera la sélection après ces
championnats du monde ce marseillais de
57 ans aura conduit le vandale français
au plus haut niveau dans la préparation
physique comme pour le spectacle fourni
portrait julien richard didier rancoeur
en guise de planches il a opté pour les
parcs et daniel costantini entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de handball
vous êtes en son métier un je ne sais
quoi de théâtre un jeu de metteur en
scène mais ça fait rien quand on rentre
dans une salle en mal il va y avoir une
représentation
vous allez avoir un rôle à jouer dans sa
représentation les gens qui vont assurer
cette représentation chez vous qui les
avez mis en mouvement
il ya une émotion formidable oscars de
la persévérance césar de l'humilité
costantini est depuis quinze ans à la
tête des bleus à son arrivée le handball
français n'est rien ou si peu
il le façonne le modèle le forge de
toutes pièces 1992 la génération barjots
décroche le bronze des jo de barcelone
1995 elle devient championne du monde
elle smoothie le destin des bleus c'est
son destin à l'iss
des lillois pfizer disparu plus ou moins
vite en plus ou moins marqué l'équipe de
france est par contre lui restait et je
pense que s'il restait en accomplissant
ses objectifs chaque fois la russie sans
c'est que quelque part il y avait une
bonne raison et la réponse de la bonne
compétence aujourd'hui la france est en
quarts de finale de ces championnats du
monde
costantini dirige une dernière fois les
tricolores avec le trac du des buts on
savait qu'elle n'avait qu à travers ce
lapin à 15 heures qu'on a vécu
pratiquement que pour ça et comme se dit
que sa raison de vivre
après ce championnat du monde c'est
pascal doit être c'est sûr qu on y
attache beaucoup d'importance
la première réussie de costantini ce
dernier ses hommes dans l'élite du
handball
la seconde fut de les y maintenir à la
fin du mondial daniel costantini va se
retirer et son métier va lui manquer